alain chamfort nous manquer après
quelques années de silence il nous
revient avec un nouvel album qui porte
bien son nom
le plaisir celui d'écouter cet artiste
qui trace depuis 30 ans sa route
christophe airaud mathieu deux jours
c'est sûrement la devinette de la
rentrée musicale quel chanteur de charme
se cache derrière ses dreadlocks et ses
tissus des six
réponse c'est alain chamfort et en plus
elle fait rire s'amusant et puis il faut
il faut essayer de continuer à s'amuser
c'est important de retrouver le désir
leur doublé son aide et des enfants
quand on fait des métiers comme ça dont
il faut continuer à jouer quoi il est
deux
alain chamfort ce grand enfant l'ex
miner la variété ou le manureva de
gainsbourg depuis 30 ans toujours un peu
transformiste il cache bien son jeu
demande de définition a marqué
dominicaux son directeur artistique
après avoir été celui d'henri salvador
séparé superficielle par moments a pu
finalement à la réécoute au détour d'une
phrase d'une ville mélodique havas
finalement ces fouilles est en fait ces
fouilles et c'est travailler mais c'est
léger voilà c'est peut-être certains
voient là le style il est peut-être un
peu un peu là entre autres
tout est dit vous avez besoin
il n'aurait donc rien à rajouter juste à
slalomer entre ces petits bonheurs du
jour et les illusions perdues d'hier
je préfère être dans mon univers un peu
un peu je dirais enfantin presque un peu
marginalisé un peu protégé un peu à
l'écart
et puis et essayer d'entretenir cette
illusion là et là elle a proposé après
un peu aux autres pour que de temps en
temps ils ont des petits lisez aussi des
épices espace de tranquillité quoi de
2,2 d'apaisement
sourire 2
passons
inquiète
des inquiétudes voilées parlent et
désinvolture ce serait donc ça le vrai
visage d'alain chamfort cinéma